il suffisait d'y penser la chartre
petite ville touristique berceau du
romantisme et de george sand s'expose
dans les vitrines du centre-ville pour
la bonne cause
permettent d'avoir un aperçu pendant les
travaux des richesse picturale du musée
à l'hôtel notre dame on a été séduit par
le concept
ça fait des dépôts la visite et de la
châtre et ça surtout ça fait vivre ça
fait habiller ça embellit s'embellit par
des belles gravures ou des photos peu
importe mais je trouve ça embellit la
ville on a 26 oeuvres au total qui ont
été reproduites et disposés sur une
quinzaine de vitrines de commerçants de
la ville de la châtre on a vraiment
conçu cette exposition comme si elle
était dans les murs d'une salle
d'exposition
donc on a choisi des emplacements on a
déjà la ville a pris contact à des
commerçants savoir s'il était d'accord
enfin voilà on a fait pris les mesures
et on voulait absolument dans la ville
montrer des oeuvres qui représentait la
ville certains tableaux ont été
redécouverts au cours du récolement
autrement dit l'inventaire des
collections
le choix s'est porté sur une sélection
d'oeuvres ayant trait à la châtre et à
ses personnalités les plus marquantes
l'accueil auprès des promeneurs est
plutôt bon j'ai remarqué puis je trouve
ça super intéressant que ce soit pour
les jeunes pour les personnes qui ne
connaissent pas la châtre ils peuvent
passer c'est super intéressant
ça évite d'aller visiter le musée entre
temps mais c'est super intéressant
des touristes qui passent par la châtre
donc ça leur permet de découvrir
justement
les oeuvres de cette région et de mieux
connaître
la ville de la chatte qu'il est très
accueillant le service culturel de la
ville a décidé de communiquer autour de
cette installation pour en faire un
atout supplémentaire à la visite de la
cité le musée non seulement à fait les
reproductions mais a créé un petit
fascicule qui répertorie tous les
endroits où sont ces reproductions donc
comme ça c'est un petit une petite
chasse au trésor laissant passer la
lumière très facile d'installation et
déposables les fac similés pourront être
réutilisés sur d'autres devanture en cas
de relocation des locaux vacants
l'exposition sera en place jusqu'à la
fin des travaux du musée prévue pour le
troisième trimestre 2010